first we've got to get to this flight
cancellations causing some major
headaches for travelers out there again
as staffing shortages and bad weather
forced many airlines to ground flight so
far today
a whopping 2 400 flights have been
canceled meanwhile many americans still
struggling to afford food the basics and
prices at the store keep climbing but
don't expect the democrats to accept
responsibility for this mess
they are too busy blaming everyone else
with all of the
constraints that covet has played look
we have the warren roth we have coveted
which has
really
deterred more product coming into our
country either by design or just by
marketplace factors
she said war in iraq but thinks she
meant war in ukraine and if it's not
food it is gas that is way too expensive
for all of us with the average today
reaching 4.99
a gallon that's up almost two dollars
from last year but according to
president biden that's not his fault
either
so if you're just facing what a barrel
of oil costing actually it should not be
decided to make it exorbitant or profit
number one
number two i've contacted them with my
team ads
to ask what their plans are and to give
any suggestions they have
they have over 9 000 leases
9 000
they can drill so
hell won't have it
but they're not doing it number two
number three
i think we're going to be in a position
where we're gonna
all right let's get to it i know we all
have a lot to say kitty let's start with
you i mean this is probably the biggest
criticism right of the biden
administration is take responsibility
tackle it head on the buck stops with
who well and it's not just take
responsibility and be accountable as the
president but also joe biden campaigned
as an empathetic figure who understood
the problems that the poor and working
class classes had he talks about how
when things go up in price it affects
you at your kitchen table he's not
acting like that you know he he said
those comments outside of the marine one
where he flew off to delaware for the
week where he is for the beach and the
truth is that americans are getting hit
just on main street of course but also
on wall street so on main street diesel
fuel is above six dollars and 40 cents
on average across the country how do you
think that people get their groceries at
the store on trucks and trip you know
that take goods from the farm such a
great product like diesel the price of
diesel being high to me is a bigger deal
than the price of gas because that
that's not just convenience hey can i go
to the movies that is hey can i make my
living today you have a truck with a
bunch of lawn care equipment on it
everything on that truck takes gas and
then the diesel truck gets it there
you're absolutely right let me can i
piggyback on that because actually you
did that piece last week in nevada about
the man who's talking about walking to
his job because he can't afford gas and
you guys are all wrong california price
of gas diesel six seven eight nine bucks
a gallon leo i'm not wrong because i
don't live there well i'm all right i'm
the wrong because i live there but let
me just make one last point that segment
that opening video segment they're all
in denial the democrats need to look in
the mirror because the problem is the
democrats well that's the thing at the
end of the day right it's it's impacting
you at home the average american you're
talking about that guy salvador munoz
when he told me that i mean my heart
sank into my stomach and i thought to
myself it is a hundred and nine degrees
outside we are barely able to sit here
and have this conversation and you are
thinking about walking
to your overnight shift one of two jobs
because you can't afford gasoline
and then and then another woman told me
she works for gas she works for food and
there's nothing left over i mean this is
what americans are going through it's
like how much worse does it have to get
well i actually read a story this
morning about a pawn shop in lubbock
texas now people are coming in with
their valuables and pawning off their
valuable
possessions in order to to make money to
pay for gas i mean that is horrific and
then you take a look at people's 401k
plans and that has been completely wiped
out i mean the fact that the stock
market is had a crash this week that's
not that's worse than march 2020 when
the whole world was shutting down years
of people's lives of working hard to
save money for for their retirement has
been completely let me tell you i grew
up that way i grew up hey we got to sell
our hunting rifles at the end of hunting
season because we can't afford to have
500 tied up in something we're not going
to use until next fall i know what it's
like to live that way i know what it's
like to go shopping for christmas in a
pond shop and see stuff that you put
there last year because you didn't have
the money to keep it we worked really
hard to get out of that and for anybody
getting put back in it after the four
years we had under trump it's a disgrace
to this country because when you tell
that story about somebody walking to
work there's two two realities there one
is reality of people in this country the
other is reality of who they are and
what they're willing to do to make it
did you notice that the in that segment
that we saw the failure of the media
other than peter ducey to push back
on these false representations what
nancy pelosi was saying no she got it
right
right but they don't push back because
of them the media is in the pocket of
the democratic party except for peter
they're not in biden's pocket so much
anymore though well no they're
criticizing him but i'm telling you
right now he's sitting there giving
these basically lies about the state of
the economy and why it's in such a bad
well i will say i think it is reflecting
in the polls so fox news just came out
with a
batch of fresh polls let's pull this one
this is brian's a job approval rating 39
of americans out there
approve which means
58 he is super
underwater drowning
i mean i they only have a few more
months left before before the midterms
and and i would think democrats all over
america are looking to
the leader of their party to to do
something about it jimmy carter is very
happy right now because this is the
worst president in the last few years
you say 39 of americans approve of him i
didn't know that many people say today
paul you haven't i didn't know that many
people lived in georgetown and
connecticut
i mean who else is happy with this no
one like
also you know you think about
will this change where is this coming
from how is it that the country went so
quickly into the the tank when it comes
to economy if you take a look at joe
biden's national economic economic
council there are more people on that
who have a ideology similar to bernie
sanders than they do to larry summers
under obama for example and let's
remember that bernie sanders is now the
senate budget committee chairman and he
at one time praised nicaraguan
breadlines from the government as a an
example of how the government was
functioning uh for their people and that
it was that breadlines were a strength
of an economy well
that's where we are and you're seeing
now all these prices and a shortage of
pretty much everything around the
country the supply chains and they think
that's just just fine well in americans
just voters just rejected his candidate
in nevada against dina titus i think it
was amy vallaila bernie sanders endorsed
candidate didn't make it through
so on this topic real quick you kind of
introduced this entire topic talking
about gas prices talking about this clip
of biden blaming the oil companies and
and i think what's really funny about
all of this is there's there's a clip
that's circulating social media jason
smith congressman i believe out of utah
not very big you know stir of things
he's grilling janet yellen i believe it
was about inflation and how inflation's
tied to government spending and she
admits that their strategy for tackling
inflation
is to try to reduce deficit he doesn't
go there but it's pretty easy if you
reduce deficit to reduce inflation does
that mean spending a trillion dollars
might be why we raised inflation and so
even going around the mountain they
they're not taking responsibility but in
her own words she kind of created that
uh that assimilation there and so when
you look at what they're trying to do
they're going to hand out government gas
cards
right they're going to they're going to
supercharge demand with taxpayer money
all that's going to do is keep prices
high that's a joke and besides what
katie said about the influence of bernie
sanders let's be very clear the biden
administration did everything possible
to undo everything trump did everything
the energy independence they tried to
just basically erase four years and
we're suffering from that and people can
make a fair comparison of what the biden
administration has done and how we were
living on january 20th 2021 well now
that things are getting bad and showing
up in the polls ahead of the midterms we
have janet yellen saying they made a
mistake on inflation inflation they
didn't see it coming they saw it coming
they just made a political calculation
yes back when president fiden wanted to
pass build back better and when he
wanted to pass the american rescue act
the 1.9 trillion dollar bill which
shot inflation through the roof they
made the calculation that it was more
important for joe biden to get a win
politically on that issue to be a
transformational president than to say
maybe this is going to hurt the american
people down the road and make a better
economic decision really quickly i'm
going to poll you guys
are we headed into a recession with this
three-quarter of a rate interest hike
i'm not economist i don't know i'll tell
you that people at home don't care they
already feel it yeah i think we already
are in a recession wow i talk economics
in 11th grade the answer is yes
okay you heard it there first hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else